[Music]
welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight for
generations the Commonwealth of Virginia
had a pretty good reputation it was
famous for its verdant horse farms the
subtle beauty of its mountains and the
gentlemanly common-sense of its politics
eight American presidents came for
Virginia including of course our first
president George Washington the
Declaration of Independence was written
by a Virginian the first Christmas tree
in this country was decorated in
Virginia Virginia was a stable sensible
place it was not Florida and yet
suddenly it is in fact just this morning
Florida mocked Virginia for getting
completely out of control in public
settled down said Florida you're
embarrassing yourself and indeed
Virginia is doing just that in the past
week that state's top three elected
officials all Democrats have fallen into
potentially career-ending scandals over
their personal behavior trainwreck does
not begin to describe what is happening
in Virginia it's been like a 50-car
pileup on i-80 one souther oh no it's a
disaster Fox is dead Henry has been
watching slack-jawed since the beginning
of this unfolding story and he joins us
now with an update hey ed Tucker good to
see it's hard to find a hero in this
mess you just laid out but maybe it's
the wife of Governor Ralph Northam who
didn't just stop him from doing the
moonwalk
she also helped convince him to not step
down despite intense pressure at the
beginning that may have turned out to be
wise counsel by Pam Northam if Northam
had given in to the political mob there
could have been a far deeper crisis in
Virginia the governorship would have
gone to Democratic lieutenant governor
Justin Fairfax
he's now embroiled in a charge of sexual
assault he denies next in line would be
Democratic State Attorney General Mark
herring
he's now admitted he too appeared in
blackface at least once in college now
in the wake of the push among some
Democrats to believe all women during
the Justice Brett Kavanaugh controversy
it's notable that a senior Democratic
congressman has now been drawn in
congressman Bobby Scott says roughly a
year ago he heard the allegations of
sexual assault from the alleged victim
herself dr. Vanessa Tyson though he just
heard there was a me-too problem but did
not hear the graphic details Tyson has
now claimed about being forced into oral
sex Fairfax is hired the same
terney who represented justice Cavanaugh
and lieutenant governor's team has fired
off a letter to NBC demanding a
correction to a report that charged in a
private meeting lieutenant governor said
of his accuser if that be Fairfax
insists he was just using profanity to
express general frustration about false
allegations new today a Republican was
drawn in state senator Tommy Norment
reportedly oversaw a yearbook at the
Virginia Military Institute in 1968
filled with racist photos and slurs he
says he did not directly edit that part
the Washington Post which published the
first allegations and against Cavanaugh
but held back on publishing a story
about the Fairfax allegations today had
an editorial saying Northam should
resign our correspondent in Richmond
Allison barber noticed one sole
pro-north and protester outside the
governor's mansion shouting through a
bullhorn I know you're a good man do not
resign Tucker oh it's unbelievable ed
Henry thank you for that judging by the
news recently it seems like an awful lot
of people are showing up at parties
dressed in costumes designed to look
like members of another race blackface
suddenly seems ubiquitous but is it what
percentage of the American population do
you think has publicly appeared in
blackface have you done it yourself do
you know anyone else who has probably
not the real number has to be pretty low
now ask yourself what percentage of
high-profile progressives have worn
black face in public
let's see two of the three highest
ranking Democrats in the state of
Virginia are white and both of them have
worn blackface as this statistical
matter that is an astounding ratio but
it probably shouldn't surprise us
blackface turns out to be fairly common
on the elite left actor Ted Danson won't
shut up showed up at a Friars Club roast
for his girlfriend will be Goldberg
wearing blackface Goldberg now co-host
the view on ABC the view is a show that
covers the intersection of scandal and
politics and yet strangely its co-hosts
have said very little about the
blackface controversy now unfolding in
Virginia and maybe that's why or
possibly it's because Goldberg's
Holling Joy Behar has also appeared in
blackface we know that because Behar
once bragged about it oh you know this
picture that is me I work what what
you're in a circle 1:29 it was a
Halloween party I went as a beautiful
African woman oh yes you ain't black
that is me did you have tanning lotion I
had makeup that was a little bit better
than my hair well given the new
standards were living under that's a
little shocking actor Sarah Silverman
won't judge Behar though Silverman has
appeared in blackface - she's got that
in common with her longtime boyfriend
Jimmy Kimmel also of ABC Kim will not
only wore black face but he affected
what it used to be called an urban
accent he did that on camera over an NBC
there's been quite a bit of blackface
over the years that you'd never know it
from how the network attacked its former
anchor megyn kelly kelly for the record
has never appeared in blackface she's
never even performed next to someone in
blackface she merely asked a question
about blackface you can't say the same
thing for Tom Hanks though watch this
[Music]
Tom Hanks works in the movie business
you'd think his peers would be deeply
offended by the tape you just saw but
they're not keep in mind that Hollywood
once produced a movie whose lead
character wore blackface for much of the
film the movie was called soul man and
came out in 1986 if that seems like a
long time ago keep in mind that it was
after Ronald Reagan made Martin Luther
King the subject of a national holiday
attitudes in America really weren't that
different back then blackface was not a
mainstream phenomenon in 1986 Hollywood
just couldn't imagine living by its own
rules then or now it's pretty clear that
the very people most likely to wear
blackface are also the most likely to
demand that
you get fired if you do the same that's
the definition of hypocrisy but it's
deeper than that
hypocrisy isn't simply a recurring
feature of modern liberalism it's the
whole point of it being a progressive
allows you to attack others for the very
same sins that you yourself are
committing in greater abundance and
that's not just true if wearing
blackface it's true of everything let's
say you got rich doing something that
earlier generations would have
recognized as dishonorable if not
criminal you manipulated international
currency markets for example where you
place two huge bets in the stock market
based on insider information or you
stripped functioning companies for parts
and left the employees with nothing
let's say you made a quick bundle doing
something like that and many have in
order to show your friends just how rich
you were you'd then of course purchase
the usual vulgar merit badges the
private airplanes
Walda states football sized yachts the
point would be to brag about your wealth
and yet on some level you wouldn't feel
especially good about this why would you
you didn't help anyone but yourself
you're a selfish and mediocre person and
you know it so how would you make
yourself feel better giving the money
back is too obvious and also too costly
maintaining your yacht is expensive you
need the money instead you might decide
to join a movement that accuses other
people of destroying the planet by
consuming too much suddenly your own
overconsumption might not seem so sinful
at least you're a deeply caring person
and you'd tell yourself that as you flew
private to global warming conferences
all over the world that's what Tom
Steyer did and Mike Bloomberg and
Leonardo DiCaprio that's what they tell
themselves
this attitude defines a ruling class
once you understand that contemporary
politics comes into focus why are people
with private security forces demanding
that you give up your guns how come so
many womanisers pose as feminists how
did Ted Kennedy lead the women's
movement after he abandoned a young
woman to die at the scene of a drunk
driving accident he caused another on
the subject why is it always at the very
people who attack others on the basis of
their skin color happen to be the first
B
to lecture the rest of us about racism
what is all this well they know they're
guilty of the very same things it all
makes sense now
ask any waiter how well progressives tip
seriously ask a waiter a group of
aggressive activists arrives at a
restaurant they linger for hours
delivering passionate lectures about the
horrors of income inequality when they
leave they shaft to the working people
who serve them food the very people they
claim to care about only with
progressivism is this behavior possible
precisely because they care so much
about structural inequality progressives
don't have to leave actual cash on an
actual table for actual workers their
tip is their profound sense of caring
too bad waiters can't pay the rent with
that this is all a profound departure
from what we have had before
conventional politics concerns itself
with improving people's lives we can
argue about how to do that but the goal
is always the same always has been the
same to make citizens happier safer more
content and prosperous modern
progressivism is very different it has
nothing to do with any of that modern
progressives care about virtue and
redemption and the expiation of sin
that's not a political philosophy it's a
religion an especially rigid form of
religion the kind of religion that
produces witch hunts and inquisitions